tras un mes en turquía machaín y cha
llegan al aeropuerto de tbilisi la
pareja originaria de moscú salió de
rusia a principios de marzo con su hijo
de nueve meses
rusia que aisladas nuestro ayuno no
tiene futuro allá parece que nos
dirigimos directamente al escenario de
corea del norte o al regreso del
nombre una idea loca de ir a liberar a
un pueblo que no necesita ser liberado
de la montaña
lógica porque es más libre que la gente
en rusia
como ellos decenas de miles de rusos lo
dejaron todo
para huir a la libertad bajo el cielo de
georgia
hay banderas ucranianas por todas partes
eso es lo primero que uno nota ser gay
tiene 20 años es diseñador él también se
fue de moscú al principio de la guerra
no podría haber deseado un cambio mejor
cuando todo ese infierno de la zeta que
te rodea en moscú es reemplazado por las
banderas ucranianas en tbilisi
pero sigue encontrándose con gente que
conoce
esa es mi vida y vamos a rentar un
apartamento juntos todos los días me
encuentro con gente que había visto en
rusia anteayer vi a un tipo que me había
vendido en una gorra nunca
sergei se marchó porque en moscú ya
había trabajado como voluntario en una
ong de ayuda a ucrania con sede en
inició su trabajo consiste en ayudar a
los civiles ucranianos a huir de las
zonas que su país está bombardeando
creamos este mapa para los miembros de
nuestro equipo
y nos permite elaborar los corredores de
evacuación para los refugiados gracias a
este mapa podemos salvar a la gente
encontrando las rutas menos peligrosas
entre los fundadores de esta ong esta
irina fabianova ex jefa de la sede de
alexéi navalni en san petersburgo se
puede rusia el pasado mes de noviembre
anteriormente todas las estructuras del
opositor número 1 de vladimir putin
encarcelado el mismo en rusia habían
sido declaradas extremistas por el
estado ruso
de repente mucha gente se dé cuenta de
hacia dónde nos estábamos dirigiendo
desde hace mucho tiempo desde el punto
de vista de quienes viven en rusia y se
han enfrentado a la represión no creo
que haya ocurrido nada nuevo había
preparado el terreno sufrimiento
totalmente la glasnot y la posibilidad
de que la gente se manifestara y
tuvieron que destruir a todos los que en
rusia llamaban a salir a las calles a
manifestarse destruyeron todas las
organizaciones de derechos humanos y los
medios de comunicación y ni siquiera
estoy hablando del envenenamiento alexéi
navalni en 2020
pero fue después del ataque a ucrania el
24 de febrero cuando el estado ruso
terminó de destruir los últimos medios
de comunicación independientes del país
este martes por la noche y con shiancoe
y ekaterina country cats se preparan
para su programa semanal de noticias
emitido en directo en youtube
nos gustaría estar en casa es muy
difícil es complicado ver lo que pasa en
rusia estando en georgia bilis él es el
redactor jefe y ella la presentadora
estrella del canal opositor 2 cerrado en
rusia desde principios de marzo
por supuesto la mayor parte de nuestro
programa se ha dedicado a la guerra
en rusia existe ahora una censura a la
guerra aprobaron una nueva ley según la
cual el llamado descrédito de las
fuerzas armadas de la federación rusa y
la llamada información falsa sobre sus
actividades se castiga con hasta 15 años
de prisión decimos que al estar libres y
seguros y tener la oportunidad de
informar si bien seríamos más útiles
para nuestras familias y oyentes que en
la cárcel no es ni para disney
aquí hay algunos artefactos de mi vida
moscovita hoy los colgué en la pared
está el boleto de mi vuelo de salida
algunas fotos de mi mamá y de mi hermana
y una vieja película nos volvemos a
encontrar con sergey que comparte este
apartamento en tbilisi con otros tres
jóvenes rusos esta es la segunda sala
común incluso hay una chimenea
aquí es donde nos reunimos y pasamos el
tiempo puede hacer quintales quien
quiere sus discusiones giran en torno a
problemas administrativos
grandes sean los iniciados en el tema
[Música]
su amor oscila entre la incertidumbre y
la esperanza de un futuro mejor
tengo la absoluta sensación de no ser
nadie
y vivir en un bloque de hielo suspendido
en la cima de una montaña
en posibilidad de ir a alguna parte es
bastante aterrador
no sé queremos irnos
por ejemplo yo quiero ir a hacer un
máster
[Música]
ya sea en francia o en inglaterra
y
la noche avanza el ambiente se relaja
tienen sueños y el mundo es suyo también
están seguros de una cosa
mientras reine vladimir putin no hay
vuelta atrás para ellos